welcome everybody we are here with the
first day of the kyle rittenhouse trial
happening in wisconsin we're joining
jury selection in progress it's so great
to have everybody with me
we're going to have a bunch of time to
talk about different things and
different elements that are going on so
um let's just jump right into this here
is the judge this is the same judge who
said the victims can't be called victims
and we're going to talk about that to
some degree um so let's just let's
listen a little bit let's jump right in
we'll start to see people's super chats
and things come in um here we go had
prior opinions about it we do want to
know about it if
if you're asked
but
if you're confident and can assure us
that
i realize the very strong distinction
between
the safeguards built into our system
and what's out in the general population
and understand that if you do that then
there's not a problem so you needn't be
concerned about having previously formed
some impressions about it as long as you
can follow the rules we've talked about
so what do you think
i was trying
well
you bear with me uh and obviously i've
got a big responsibility here of making
a decision and
let me ask it this way do you think
you are any less you you think you are
any less able to be fair in this case
than anybody else who is here
no problem
probably not oh boy this is already a
concerning juror guys
okay thank you thank you very much
uh probably not next
uh number five
well what would happen if if the
evidence developed and it actually was
different
it sounds like these potential jurors
are saying i don't know that i can be
objective and the judge is like it
sounds great to me would you be able to
set your opinion aside then
no you couldn't
in spite of
actually hearing from people who
actually saw or even videoed
what happened you wouldn't be able to
put that aside oh boy
okay any reason this juror shouldn't be
excused
okay thank you ma'am
uh call up the next please
[Music]
yep uh ma'am would you have answered or
raised your hand rather to any of the
questions asked so far
thank you very much would you take seat
to number five there please
okay now that back row again anybody
else i see a number
let's give it a second here
i don't think it put my feelings aside
i know quite a few police officers and
fighter fighters
i heard you say you knew the quite a few
police officers and firefighters and i
dared to listen i don't i can't put my
feelings aside
what's funny is the case is shouldn't be
about police officers except we know the
defense plans to make it about that
counter
instance
well you know what you think but
we're talking about
hearing the actual evidence
right
so if you heard
someone testify
directly contrary
to
and let's say you heard four witnesses
who are directly contrary
to what you think
the case was based upon what you've
heard or
or what you
see
yeah i've seen you wouldn't be able to
to disregard the the
okay
any reason this juror shouldn't be
excused no so
this happens and a lot of people don't
want to be stuck for weeks at this thing
so a lot of people will lie you know the
old thing used to be say that you're
racist be like whatever the defendant is
be like i'm racist and and the idea is
to get out
so there's no doubt that to some degree
there are people here who are saying
that at the same time if somebody tells
you hey i don't think i can be objective
you need to seriously consider that but
it's already got mistrial all over it
particularly with the instructions to
the prosecution you can't refer to the
victims as victims which we'll talk
about okay we're just getting into this
here in answer to any of the questions
asked so far
thank you very much sir would you take a
seat number eight
okay anybody else uh in the last
question was um
was um
if you've ever formed or expressed any
opinion now have
or express any opinion as to the
innocence or guilt of the just dropping
it in
without hearing the evidence
um
what's your number sir
17 and what's up
my biases
go back to
14 months ago i've been commenting
consistently on news feeds and facebook
it also goes a little further to my
belief in the second amendment which
comes from monroe's writings
he's
i'll read your website
and yeah but you know here
no no i i'm gonna tell you
and you didn't do that you haven't done
a thing a single thing wrong but
as i i said before if i didn't say it
i'll say it again this is not
a political
trial
the this the one of the problems with
the way the media has covered this the
guy's basically saying
for me
i just believe in the second amendment
so i'm likely to side with the guy who
did the shooting that's what the juror
is saying here in some instances very
very imprudently
you know they're important issues for
those
who seek to lead our country to discuss
what the innocence or guilt of an
individual accused of a crime is not one
of them
and um
also the trial is not it's not about
what whether
to the extent the trial is about the
constitution
it's about the right
to a fair trial
and i i i don't want you to take this a
lecture my point is that
we don't want to fall into the trap just
dismiss the guy dude come on get him out
of here percentage of the media and
discuss this as a political trial
uh or that there are
bigger factors than this case at stake
in this trial
we're concerned here in this courtroom
to try this case in accord with our law
between the things the judge has already
said and the cartoonish nature of some
of these potential jurors
this trial already seems destined for
disastrous mistrial i mean it
or or not guilty not guilty was my
initial thought wonderful system that
was given to us by our founders
it hasn't always worked perfectly and in
fact there's some very shameful chapters
in the history
of the jury's
determinations in this country but i've
been in this business for 50 years
and interesting to call it a business
it's a lot better now
than it was
uh 50 years ago
and if we keep at it
and try to
contain by the way i'm ban hammering
people it's like almost impossible to
keep up to how many people were banning
already it's crazy
so i want the the this case to reflect
the greatness of kenosha
and the fairness of kenosha
and i don't want it to get sidetracked
into other issues now
i don't care about your opinions on the
second amendment or somebody else's that
are directly contrary
one of the beauties of the jury system
although it's not intended is that it
brings together the a composite of the
community dear god it isn't just being a
case isn't being decided on political
basis it's being decided
if it's done properly on the basis of
what is the law saying
what are the true facts that's what the
jury decides is what are the true facts
and how do they fit together and that
comes out as a verdict
so
you
i'm sure you'll be questioned here when
we go into the private discussions i'm
sure you'll be questioned about anything
that you put out on the internet or what
discussions you've had
but they're not disqualifying
the guy is saying i'm a second amendment
nut and i'm in favor of the shooters and
the judge is like the things you've told
me are not disqualifying um
i just don't want to get into a
discussion now where we're talking about
the second amendment can you imagine or
anything like that because this case is
not [ __ ]
it may
the the second amendment like all the
constitutional provisions have a role in
this case but they are not the focus of
this case okay
uh if i'm going on that's
bear with me okay so do you think you
can be fair in this case
no i do not
do you think that there are other people
here who are going to be fairer than you
would be
i have no idea how to answer that okay i
would hope so
i think you're biased
this guy's honest i guess i do when they
go back to the politics
that you told me to stop no i yeah okay
okay
um any reason this gentleman shouldn't
be excused no okay thank you sir i guess
he's gone
after the lecture the guy's like yeah
i'm biased you're out of here
wow
thanks to hal dardo for the twitch prime
sub appreciate that also thanks to
twisted hawk appreciated
we also have a coupon code today
elements of bathrooms
gets you 69
off this is jury selection day one
of the kyle rittenhouse
murder trial
intentional homicide is at issue as well
as a number of other charges oh i'm
sorry uh man would you have raised your
hand and answer to any of the questions
asked so far
okay that's don't you don't be bashful
about it
um just voiced my opinion about this to
a lot of people okay
well
number one
is it possible that your opinion
whatever it is can be changed yes if you
heard the evidence in the case which has
the safeguards we talked about do you
think you could put aside what you've
said before and decide solely on the
evidence
do you think that you'll have to
once you're on the jury you might have
to swallow your pride and tell your
friends you know i actually heard all
the evidence yeah and
will you be able to do that yeah i'm
going to put you in that seat then and
we'll see what happens number 17 please
so what they're doing now for everybody
to understand is they're going through
an initial selection in order of
people's jury numbers to get people
seated
then
if you make it through this then both
sides attorneys get to ask more specific
questions and can move to strike
i could be impartial
only given that the facts presented
were given to both sides
so
so just as you said stated
judge is confused
judge is like holy [ __ ] this trial is
going to be a [ __ ] show
than the news did
so all the news clips that were
showing up
were
not
favorable for him
and what i'm definitely afraid of right
now is yes i have somewhat of a
preconceived notion which i could
overlook but if given through the trial
you're starting to see that
it's a one-sided
i would have problems with that well
what this is what
i
what the constitution says
both sides have the right
to question the witnesses
both sides have the right to force
witnesses to attend
and to present evidence
both have the both sides are going to be
given the right to argue the case what
is this woman's complaint that there
might be one-sided claims made that's
the entire trial is the the defense puts
together a completely one-sided defense
and the prosecution puts together a
completely one-sided prosecution and
then it's up to you to decide
she doesn't know what a trial is
when every judge takes an oath from the
chief justice of the united states right
to the
municipal judge of the smallest
community in the country
every judge takes an additional oath
not just the constitutional oath but
also a judicial oath
which includes the club the
the
pledge that i will administer justice
fairly without respect to persons that
means
be fair
to everybody who comes in
don't be looking at who's involved
without respect to people that doesn't
mean you don't respect people it means
you don't give an advantage to a bank
for people asking i have done jury duty
i discharged my duty as a juror
and i'll talk about it during the the
upcoming break all that up and you
decide solely on the evidence
and um that's what is expected of the
jurors
now
you said you saw one and then you saw
another and you formed a different view
of it
and you you didn't see anything that's
evidence in the case because there's
been no evidence
you have
you have a field of uh she's like i've
already seen a lot of one-sided evidence
the trial hasn't started ma'am the only
thing that counts as evidence is what's
presented in the trial
when you have heard
all of the evidence
both part both parties being fair to
produce evidence and to challenge
evidence and argue evidence will you be
able
to be fair
no
thank you did you have your hand up uh
this number
i verbally already said that
he was guilty
i didn't hear what you said
i verbally
admitted that
i thought he was guilty and i'd be very
healthy while i'm sitting here and i
listened to it
in your
explanations in the last couple of
times here
i kept asking myself can i honestly do
that
and i keep coming up with a thing
if there's evidence there that
would be
indicating innocence
i don't think i would
the other issue is it's not innocence it
would be lack of sufficient evidence to
say guilt
i i hope i'm understanding you right but
it sounds like you've made a conclusion
early on
and
even when you consider
the the hell was that
injunction from the founders of our
country that you should decide solely on
the evidence you're not going to be able
to abandon that opinion
is that what you're saying
okay any reason this uh jury uh this
guy's gone
okay thank you sir
sir
um
what's who's next
sorry setting up my stream deck here
so that guy's gone
thanks to jen here for gifting two
twitch subs as well as dirt knapp and
market mainer also lord labrand very
much appreciate it
all right number 47 uh would you have
raised your hand and answered to any of
the questions asked so far yes sir
what's
up i'm a self-employed title contractor
and i have a job
in a house that is closing next friday
that isn't started yet
and it's not done those people move into
a house without a bathroom
[Music]
do you have people work with you
work for you
either how much of a financial loss
would you take if a competing contractor
were to do that work uh
4 000
that's the grosser that's the order
would be the growth
what would be the amount that you would
be out of pocket
probably 2500.
any reason this juror shouldn't be
excused
no thank you sir
yep got him out got him out 2 500 bucks
in income he's got him out
man
what do you think i mean like this is
this is the justice system folks these
are the considerations i post to
facebook i got a tile job i've got i
think the guy's guilty i'm for the
second amendment
really getting a front row seat to this
all right um sir would you have raised
your hand in answer to any of the
questions asked so far
all right would you have raised your
hand in answer to any of the questions
asked so far
okay thank you would you take seat
number 16
thank you sir right this is a good super
chat it's very clear that this community
is watching a lot of fox news that's
that's absolutely true um we have some
devices here that um
for to amplify this the
spoken voice and they also decrease the
ambient noises
and people have used them in fact i've
used them microphones they work very
well
and um
we actually we have a schedule where we
sanitize them every six weeks
so that there's no concern about putting
them in
six weeks okay we do it every day every
time they're used we do them so uh
anybody want a
hearing device
they work through this gadget up here
uh behind their infrared i don't know
anybody want one just tell the bailiff
thank you um all right um
let's see now we were going through
about people who have
expressed opinions or now have opinions
uh
and i think we're in what's your seat
number sir
19 what's up
uh but it's wait until the
obama yeah i have discussed this with
multiple officers in my family and
due to how often i've discussed it i
believe my voting and setting stone
office i do not think
my opinion is set in stone on this i do
not feel that i could have changed that
at all you know you know i'm not trying
to be obnoxious although
i can't be but um i'm not trying to be
obnoxious but
what you're telling me is that you have
discussed with other people
and no matter what the evidence is
you're you're sticking with your opinion
yes
apparently no
fair enough i'm not trying to diminish
you in any way all right any reason this
gentleman shouldn't be excused
thank you sir
another one bites the dust
thanks to blue louve as well as jg
straight shot
for the twitch prime subscriptions very
much appreciate it
if you're just joining us this is jury
selection day one of the kyle
rittenhouse murder trial a number of
potential jurors have already been
excused they are getting an initial
seating after which time the attorneys
on both sides will get to ask further
questions each has a certain number that
they can move to strike
i do want to say thanks also to brian
caserto
and melissa tarnoff both of whom just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code elements of bathrooms
thank you very much would you take seat
number 19
without tripping i think she said
all right um
anybody else now who
feels that he or she
now has or has in the past expressed
opinions to the innocence or guilt of
the defendant
uh
number
are you 25 20
26 oh yeah uh and uh what's up i'm
thanks president
okay
um whatever the opinion is can you
abandon it after hearing
well to be to have an open mind when the
evidence start and decide exclusively no
matter if it's everything you thought
about the case is true turns out not to
be fact
not to be established
even
no matter what happens you'll be able to
decide
on the basis of the evidence here in the
court absolutely
okay fair enough
uh anybody else
okay number
30 31 31 yes um i have expressed an
opinion my nephew was a police officer
and left because
i will try to be unbiased
well let me ask you this um
the up
the up roar as you refer to it the
unrest whatever you want to call it
uh is direct related to this case only
because it is the circumstances under
which it occurred
um
the case
the focus in the case needs to be on the
actions of the persons
involved
so uh there may be many there were many
aspects of what happened
uh during that period
that have really almost nothing to do
with this case
so i don't know what to you know what
your nephew what aspect of it might have
upset your nephew nephew or
or well my nephew said kyle rittenhouse
is a hero who should have killed twice
as many people and i agree with him sir
do you think there's any reason for me
to think that you are less likely to be
fair than anyone else who's here yeah
that she's telling you okay thank you
okay 32.
i said express um opinions when this all
went down from kenosha so
very deep rooted in the city and
i have had my opinions i think the
problem i have is
the amount and extensive people that i
do know in kenosha and how deep our
opinions are about certain things i
think it would be very hard for me to
not have outside influences during this
time
okay
number one
um are you aware you'll be sequestered
with no tv in the equation
um just as when i was started talking
about my
uh pals in school
uh
it was hard for many of them and
frightening i'm sure
but they had to do it
because that was their duty
as far as influence by others
one of the instructions i'm going to
give those who were selected for the
jury is they're not allowed to discuss
the case with anyone not even members of
their immediate family much less anybody
else
and um
maybe they're not going to be
sequestered by the way in all
seriousness okay to say
i'm serving on a jury
but then follow up with and the judge
told me
that if i talk with you about it
we'll both be in really
big
trouble and that's such a perfect thing
to say
because it's the truth
and we don't want to go there believe me
neither of us does but especially you
you don't want to talk about the gays
and in fact what i sometimes will tell
people who get funny about it
is i'll tell them funny how they'll give
me their opinion
about a case and i'm not talking about
this one look at me with their opinion
about a pending case
and i'll say you have me at a
disadvantage because i haven't heard the
evidence yet
and of course they haven't either and
they should feel like fools for even
doing that
but as i said it's a human tendency to
form some impressions and all that stuff
that's all okay
but when you're coming here in the
courtroom and you're on the jury you're
like one of the cardinals when they
elect the pope they lock them up
and
and the reason they do it if you
research the history there's some really
fascinating reading about how papal
elections used to take place
and so they
when they cleaned it up they said we're
going to lock them all up in the room
and they're not coming out until they
um they're not going to be subject to
influences by this one or that one or
anybody else and so
i know you're well connected
uh and for the record i'm acquainted
with this person
uh oh god um she's
uh well known to a member of my family
okay she should be gone
uh
what the hell but i don't see her even
maybe a couple of times a year um
[Music]
well i think i see her at church uh more
frequently than that but beyond that i
don't typically have discussion with her
but um
so she's well acquainted and what the
[ __ ]
but um
obama every juror is just going to have
to who's selected
is just going to have to have a
the you might is this a six is this 12
people one of the 12 people might be an
acquaintance of the judge
do you think you have opinions we don't
see each other more than weekly at a
church but you cannot
discard entirely in disguise and decide
this case solely
as you view the evidence in this case
that would be difficult for me
once again you're talking about
difficult
do you think that they're unable to
pardon me i'd be unable to do that are
you do you think that there's others
here who are more able to be fair than
you
i believe so okay any reason unless the
solution excuse me okay thank you
holy [ __ ] guys
see you on sunday
i want to say a huge thank you to mike r
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code felony21 also greg
feingold signing up with the coupon code
elements of bathrooms new members uh 12
and 13 very much appreciate that coupon
code right above my head
oh yeah excuse me um
and you are number 33 uh
also sorry big thank you to the last
scrap dragon and zach washer who just
signed up via twitch prime
i
for religious reasons
thou shall not kill
whoa
that's my opinion it's been that way for
a year that's interesting
i'm biased folks
well let me and i understand that and i
i don't want to
suggest that you should do anything in
violation of the religious place that
you hold
um
however um
i think most religious faiths
accommodate the belief in self-defense
and that's going to be an issue in this
case the state is contending that these
crimes were committed
the law provides that uh self-defense is
a defense and that people have the
lawful right to defend themselves i
think most religious groups
believe that
i think that um
uh when for example the uh
we're doing during the attack on pearl
harbor back in 1941 oh my god um
the the members of our military the the
sailors
uh were on the ship and all of a sudden
uh planes come and start shooting at
them and dropping bombs on them
you know
i think most religious
uh
belief would be that they could
morally
return fire and try literally to kill
those who are attacking them oh my god
to save their own lives and those of
their colleagues
so
i i want to make sure that
you you know those i think that a large
segment of the group here perhaps
everybody who's here
would agree with the with the uh
with the proposition we're all religious
thou shalt not kill oh my god but we'll
be open to what
moral belief is
but more importantly because this we
have secular
institutions in this country in this
court here we are bound by the law of
the system
regardless of your personal beliefs
on the subject of the morality
of uh
of
self-defense if it is self-defense i'm
not saying it is if it's self-defense
it is our law
that the jury is not to convict if the
jury believes that the defendant acted
in self-defense and i don't want to get
bogged down on that right now but
do you think you can follow our law
whether or not you agree that that
should be the law and you do and that
you think that it should be you should
turn the cheek
do you think
that you can
follow the law in terms of making your
verdict
and
[Music]
examine the evidence and decide whether
the case is self-defense can you do that
no i have to follow god's laws
okay uh any uh reason this juror
shouldn't be excused thank you ma'am hey
listen she's being honest she's being
honest and that's good i want to say a
huge thank you to laura murr james clues
and alex creator for subscribing via
twitch prime jen here has also gifted
two putting us at 20 already we also
today we may cover the entire trial
depending on how today goes i want to
say thanks to michael wells for signing
up on my website with the coupon code
elements of bathrooms which saves you 69
great day to do it we may even have a
second stream tonight the final rallies
in virginia
all right ma'am would you have raised
your hand in answer to any of the
questions asked so far i have a general
and a specific bias
okay
you
i i with the intensity with which you
say it it sounds like that
you're not open to the what the evidence
shows
in general people are jerks dogs
and specifically
my dad's field was supposed to be on
august 25th that night we had to be
scheduled because of everything that was
going on what's she saying no nobody
here is
uh
nobody here is charged with
with
being disorderly the actual crimes are
very specific and they're a lot more
serious than that but she had plans
ruined by the riot ascent
the unlawful behavior
those are not the issues and that's
frightening that
things were disturbed by every people of
people's lives including something as
touching and important as that was
destroyed by what happened but
is that
something that should her dad's funeral
is somebody involved in this case
life's about choices choices have
consequences
so okay
that's not important if people have mind
in their own business and stayed in
their own city
then honestly this will be going on
right now wow um i think she's saying if
rittenhouse hadn't come from illinois
none of this would have happened
thank you ma'am
she's gone
i mean she's right
not not an incorrect statement
in the meantime i do want to say thanks
to otto pico who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code elements of
bathrooms thank you otto also thanks to
mo bait and shot x thomas moe bates and
shot
would you have raised your
hand and answered any of the questions
asked so far
a couple of witnesses
who are they
randy valerie
okay
what's the nature of your
acquaintanceship with those folks
okay if has either of them discussed any
aspect of this with you
if either of them appeared as a witness
in the case would you judge that
person's believability by a different
standard yes from that you to employ
with complete strangers clearly okay
thank you i'm going to ask that you take
uh
seat number
10 no i guess she said no so we're up to
it looks like we're up to 10 out of the
12.
so folks i believe that after after the
initial 12 then the lawyers get to talk
to each of these people
uh number 33.
um i just
feel that i formed my own opinion
already before coming here okay and and
you're not i gather from the comments
which have been made you're not unique
in that the question is can you put that
opinion aside
and follow what the evidence shows as
opposed to an opinion you are based have
based on what you heard outside the
courtroom
no you can't do it no any reason this
lady shouldn't be excused thank you
ma'am
and off she goes
so i believe we have two more jurors and
then i think they would need two or
three alternates and then we would move
on to the next step
okay
let's see what we get
all right man would you have answered
raised your hand and answered any of the
questions asked so far okay thank you uh
would you take seat number 33
oh let's see if i can get through okay
anybody else now with an opinion
um
number
12 13 14 10 16. yeah i'm sorry
i did not hear what you say i don't
think the mic is on
the mic is not on sir
you know what i'm going to take a break
now because i just got to pop up that
the food is here and so i'm going to
break here and
discuss this with you in just a minute
if you will
uh folks i've got a pastrami on rye with
deli mustard that needs some attention
in the back
um
now
pizza is here
and um
so and i believe it's over in the other
building as well
and uh we're going to take a break um
how realistic is it to start it uh at uh
one o'clock
actually i try to go for quarter to one
but that's probably pushing it i guess
that would be 55 minutes
one
115
150 and we're going to start again now
during the break
the pizza's here if there's a problem
with that
see one of the bailiffs and we'll see
i mean a medical problem not just that
you don't like that particular
sauce but
[Music]
guys please
and um
don't talk about the case you can talk
about
with the other jurors and that you can
talk don't talk with anybody who's not
in the jury
but if you talk with other jurors you
can talk about
the packer game you can talk about the
bears game you can talk about the
blackhawks haven't won a game yet you
can talk about a lot of other things but
um
don't talk about anything about the case
anything about
the people involved
uh anything about other jurors
and um we'll try to start at one o'clock
1 15 115 and uh wow
don't use any electronic equipment don't
be going online and looking anything up
that pertains to the case
or might pertain to the case or
any news facility so it sounds like
they're not taking people's phones it's
just sort of the honest the honor system
um
and uh don't communicate with anybody
don't mention that you're gonna be
eating in the courtroom you're gonna be
eating in the courtroom allowed to leave
they're not allowed to leave okay well
they couldn't you leave to go to the
bathroom whatever you do don't
make sure you go to the bathroom
somewhere other than the courtroom
but uh
but
well it's even more specific i suppose
but anyway don't uh
don't leave the building don't talk with
anybody not involved don't um
what is happening don't go on don't be
sending messages
you can don't go on that new meta
it's about
i'll talk to you later and everything's
fine
but uh don't be discussing the
nature of what you're doing here or
anything like that please
and uh that's uh you focus on the other
building same thing
uh and when you return from using please
don't use my chambers as a toilet uh you
please
take the same seat you're in right now
any questions
all right bless you all uh we'll see you
a little bit bless you
wow guys this is off to a wild wild
start i don't think saturday night live
will be able to
do anything about this i don't i don't i
mean it's how do you
how do you satirize this right i mean
it's it's wild wild wild wild please
stay with us because they're coming
right back in about 50 minutes
um
[Music]
well a lot of drama going on there
um so listen let's see where to even
start i mean let me
let me get to let me look at some super
chats and then i'll give you my thoughts
bae photo says sequester the pizza
um
i read that there was fresh garlic on
some of the pizzas and people are
furious because they're gonna have to
sit next to each other are you serious
is the judge insane how long is he
talking about food pizza time pacman do
you plan to cover the supreme court case
on the texas abortion law uh probably
not there's just a limit to how much
stuff we can do
um all the people who want them found
guilty are being honest all the ones who
want him set free are lying to get on
the jury
love your show david thanks for the
coverage the trial by kafka makes a
hundred times more sense than this
when do they start opening statements
potentially tomorrow the judges whacked
out if he were to get off do you believe
written house would be in danger due to
the present president precedent that you
can take the law into your own hands
david sorry the stream just switched to
snl what happened with the judge in the
church
what a great reminder how unreasonable
and illogical the justice system can be
see you at the church buddy
i've been deep in jury selection
multiple times this is typical and that
judges won't give a fast dismissal to
anyone without a monologue and a back
and forth yeah so a lot of a lot of
super chats from the standpoint of this
courtroom the judge is fairly hungry
this judge seems like such an out of
touch boomer that might even be
suffering from dementia how is he the
one judging the trial well remember the
the the jury will ultimately decide on
guilt or innocence
earlier juror woman basically saying if
the court presents reality rather than
fox news propaganda i will be mad yeah
um
essentially
that is that is more or less what was
taking place
um okay wow let me get caught up on
everything that's taking place here
um over on the website i want to say
thanks to jeremy desolnier
who signed up with the coupon code
elements of bathrooms which i think
do i have that
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers i guess i don't have it today
but the coupon code is elements of
bathrooms on my website also want to say
thanks to sheldon glass who signed up
with the exact same coupon code we're
gonna be doing everything we can to do a
ton of live coverage this week in
addition to five podcasts and five bonus
shows
already filmed today's
podcast already filmed today's bonus
show this is the first stream tonight i
plan to stream the final terry mcauliffe
rally glenn younkin also has a rally
tonight trump is doing a telerally for
glenn younkin i'm planning to stream all
of it tomorrow
we're gonna probably stream day two of
the kyle rittenhouse trial and then
tomorrow night we've got a stream with
election results
i would really appreciate your uh
support of this additional content that
we're doing the best way
is just to go to my website
joinpakman.com and sign up the normal
prices are very reasonable but we have a
coupon code in case they're not elements
of bathrooms saves you 69
you can also a few other coupon codes if
you prefer you can use the coupon code
felony21 you can use the coupon code
better21 you can also use the coupon
code sad trump
surrounded by
water big water ocean apply
light and heat to
cure
it's not racist at all no not at all
donate plasma today please and then i
see the disinfectant is there a way we
can do something like that
uh by
injection inside or okay so um in any
case in all seriousness i'll thank
everybody who does sign up during
today's stream very much appreciate
everybody who's joining me uh and we are
standing by for the resumption of the
trial okay so people have been saying
hey david have you been on a on a jury
is it this insane
i was on a jury on the day of my 21st
birthday and i'm glad to talk about it
and tell you how it was insane actually
i want to say thanks to bill hubris for
the twitch prime subscription also
welcome and thanks to hack foue who is a
new twitch prime subscriber
and i really can't tell you how much i
appreciate that it's a lot okay so here
here's my jury duty trial and it was
absolutely horrible it really
um
damaged my impression
of the justice system that we have
because when they say a jury of your
peers
most people
i i don't i mean i hope this is an
offensive most people are incompetent
most people are not particularly smart
it doesn't mean they're bad people
they're just busy with their lives or
whatever okay
the trial i was in i was on jury duty on
my 21st birthday
everybody was telling me david sir
you're not going to be picked they don't
want young people they don't want
college students say you're in college
they're not going to want you
uh i said i hope that's the case
so it's an assault trial
and the facts that we are given are
essentially
that person a has been charged with
assault of person b
um
person
b
uh
the incident took place at person b's
house
and person a went to person b's house
there was an altercation and person a
ended up shoving and punching
person b
and we were to decide whether they were
guilty of assault
pretty straightforward
um they go through jury selection i
happened to be one of the first six it
was a six-person jury and just nobody
said anything i was like oh my god any
second they're going to be like get this
kid out of here get them off nobody said
anything i happened to be in the first
six
no real questions were asked other than
these questions like is do you know any
of the people here whatever the one
person that was um
struck from the jury
was a police officer who knew the police
officer who would be testifying in the
case but otherwise the first six six of
the first seven were selected and two
alternates okay
so
jury starts
uh trial starts rather there's a few
witnesses there's guy there's person b
who's the guy that was punched right is
the victim in the case he testifies
a police officer who is the police
officer that showed up
testifies there's testimony about
the
layout almost like a floor plan
of the house where this took place
uh which is relevant in a moment there's
not really that many facts i mean i
think that it was probably like a
90-minute trial
and then they send us to deliberate now
the crux of the defense was
that this was self-defense
the defense's argument was
my client
guy a the gentleman charged
did punch and shove
guy b
but it was self-defense
now
in uh at the time this was in
massachusetts in massachusetts
self-defense has a specific
legal meaning it's not self-defense you
can't just say self-defense it has to be
demonstrated to be self-defense and one
of the important aspects of the way that
the self-defense statute was read to us
at the time
was that
for it to be valid self-defense guy a
needed to have no way to just walk away
right there was no way to avoid the
confrontation altogether in other words
there's a sort of colloquially speaking
duty to retreat
um you can't just choose if someone says
hey you're a [ __ ] you don't you can't
just go and punch him in the face and
say that's self-defense you have to
actually
you know be afraid and you must have no
other option
and the reason that the
um
floor plan of the house was relevant
was that based on the floor plan and
everyone's descriptions of where people
were standing guy a had a front door
right behind him
so
the question sort of was
is it self-defense
if you can just walk out the door
right is it self-defense if guy b comes
up and intimidates me and hurls abuse at
me or whatever
if i can just walk out the back door and
leave
is it still self-defense if i punch the
guy now
my understanding based on the law was
this is guilty of assault uh it's not
been demonstrated that a punch was an
equal force a use of equal force because
no one's alleging that guy b punched guy
a was intimidating was getting up in his
face okay
but based on
was it equal force no
guy a threw a punch guy b did not
and for a valid self-defense claim
there must be no simple way to just walk
away
everybody admits the guy was standing in
front of the front door could have
turned around walked away so i'm
thinking that that's guilty
guilty it's very clear
i assume everybody is going to be on the
same page we go into the jury room and
take sort of like an initial
poll to see where people are at
and
four
of the six people
are saying not guilty i'm saying guilty
one other guy
is saying guilty everybody else is
saying not guilty
of the four people saying not guilty
two
had no idea what was going on you could
have told them we were in thailand right
now they would have been like oh okay
they they just had no they they didn't
they weren't able to articulate really
any reason why they thought anything
and i was like oh god this is already a
bad start
but then there were two guys
who were saying not guilty
who were saying dude it's self-defense
it's self-defense it's just it's
self-defense and myself and the one
other guy were saying
whatever your colloquial understanding
of self-defense is
we have to go by the instructions from
the judge about the requirements for
self-defense one of the self-defense
defense requirements is there you have a
duty to retreat and there's no simple
way to exit
nobody's contesting that the guy a is
standing with a door behind him and
could just walk away there was no
crazy aggression from guy b it was an
argument and they kind of got up in each
other's faces so
by the definition of self-defense this
couldn't have been self-defense
therefore it's guilty
and these two guys just go you know kind
of like kind of you know
country guys whatever tough guys go no
if somebody came up to you in a bar and
did that you'd punch them and they would
be self-defense man
like what do you do with that
they refuse to even engage with the
statute as written they're going by
their opinion from colloquial life about
what if what is self-defense
so
i think everybody was shocked at how
long it was taking to deliberate the
defense attorney the prosecutor the
judge and at a certain point we're
essentially deadlocked on a stupid case
on my 21st birthday
so we all go back in we have questions
for the judge
and we're almost like at a mistrial it's
crazy we're almost like as a hung jury
and we go in and it's there's a request
for the self-defense statute to be read
again and you can tell that nobody's
expecting this to take so long the judge
is sort of like okay i'll read i'll read
the self-defense stat shoot again
and the prosecutor and the defense
attorney they're all kind of like
how
what is happening in that room where
it's been two three hours and now
they're coming for clarifications that
nobody's expecting this to be going on
so we go back into the jury room and
again me and this one other guy
we say
um
it's guilty
by the it does not meet the requirements
of self-defense it's guilty
the two people who were just sort of
like
not guilty but clueless really didn't
they just stuck with not guilty and then
these two dudes insist they're like no
man that's self-defense that's
self-defense you got to stick up for
yourself man stuff like this
what ended up happening
eventually we got into a discussion
about
do we even know that the guy a threw a
punch
so this was like whoa wait what's going
on here
the discussion went further
to where they started saying these two
guys started saying
there's there's really no oth other than
the victim claiming he got punched
we don't really have evidence that a
punch was even thrown
because the police officer didn't
observe the punch the police officer
showed up after the fact
guy a didn't testify at all
so
we have one assertion that a punch was
even thrown and it's that of the victim
maybe there was no punch thrown
so at that point we go back to the judge
and and as a jury we asked the judge
are we to decide the verdict
on the basis that the assertion of the
punch is true in other words was a punch
being thrown
a part of the facts of the case
or
are we to evaluate whether we even
believe that a punch was thrown
and the judge said it's up to us to
determine whether a punch was even
thrown in other words
there was an assertion made by the
victim i got punched
it's up to us to determine whether
that's even credible so at that point we
go back to the jury room and at that
point even me and this other guy who
were like this is guilty because we
can't prove itself we all were like
listen guys we've been here six hours
if we first have to somehow determine
whether a punch was even thrown
it's just it's just not guilty there's
now doubt there's now enough doubt
there's there's
we don't really have any corroborating
witness we have we have nothing
okay
and um so then it ended up being not
guilty and we all got the hell out of
there but it was crazy i mean it was
such a simple case that when you start
hearing people hear saying
i believe this and i believe in the
second amendment and all these different
things it's like i just have no trust in
the system at all no trust that
experience just uh
it's just hard to believe it's truly
hard to believe that that's that's what
it but it is it's the system we have and
some people would say
it's uh the best possible system or
whatever the case may be
i want to say thank you to hayden king
who just signed up on my website using
the coupon code
felony21 we we are trying to get to 100
website members and twitch subscribers
if you're watching on twitch i would
love it for you to use your twitch prime
subscription on my channel if you're an
amazon prime subscriber you get a free
twitch prime sub every month you can
take five bucks out of bezos pocket if
you want and give them to a streamer or
you can leave them in jeff bezos pocket
it's your call it's your call i say use
it um also
uh sign up on my website because that's
the way you know twitch keeps like a lot
um if you go to my website we keep all
but 2.9 you go to joinpakman.com normal
prices i think are really really good
they directly support our work including
multiple streams today multiple streams
tomorrow etc etc you can use the coupon
code elements of bathrooms for a 69
discount which i think is a really great
discount
i think it's a really really good
discount and if you're just joining us
we are about a half hour from jury
selection resuming and it's going to be
uh it's going to be very interesting to
see i do want to play some voicemails
for you guys while we wait here i also
want to look at other
um super chats
david wackman says is it just
coincidence you and your pacmaniacs have
stopped defending fouchy since the story
of him torturing dogs
why admire a liar um i am talking about
anthony fauci basically as frequently as
i ever was which is roughly once every
three weeks i have seen no evidence that
anthony fauci tortured a dog
jimmy from philly says kyle is an
american hero not guilty well having not
heard the evidence jimmy it's shocking
to me that such a constitutional
conservative would take that position
you look like jeff cavaliere from
athlean x
um okay let's see jeff
cavaliere
athlean
x
see what that means
i look like this guy this seems weird
uh i don't really see it to be honest
yeah
i don't see it
but i still appreciate the super chat
earlier
okay no we already read that the
manuscript mistakenly cited support from
niaid when in fact it did not support
that research no fouchy involved it's an
adjacent bogus study with no nih
involvement
okay
very good
so we got that taken care of
i want to say thank you to
kiyoshike
as well as john robert wilson and
chrome for the twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 30 31 and 32.
really appreciate that
um let's get to a couple of other things
i have
this is a
wacky wait a second
let me see if i can
see if i can fix this so we can actually
see more of it
there we go
okay this is a guy who threw himself on
the floor the other day
because he didn't want to wear a mask i
mean just behaving like a toddler take a
look at this
um
this guy is advocating for freedom
okay
so um
yeah i mean i don't know what else to
tell you about that but that's that's
pretty humiliating behavior thanks to
jeff builds a base for subscribing via
twitch prime you're number 33 today very
much appreciate that
um and if you're just joining us it is
day one of the kyle rittenhouse trial
this is the first of two streams today
there's going to be another stream
tonight
um the final rallies in the virginia
gubernatorial race terry mcauliffe has a
rally glenn yunken i believe has a rally
and trump is doing a telerally for glenn
younkin now here's the thing if anybody
can find
um
a stream of trump's telerally
please email info at davidpakman.com
because i'm not sure if that's going to
be public or not
um bat says can we please ban la palma
erupt please for his racist jokes
uh okay let me see
oh yeah they're getting banned
immediately banned thank you for calling
that to my attention i appreciate that
this trial is bringing a lot a lot a lot
of um
racists to the channel
and other unsavory elements
jonathan says i know more well-behaved
toddlers love your show david
when the judge says there is to be no
communication with the outside world
does that include a trip advisor review
for the pizza i think it does
the david pakman show company's average
employee rating on glass door is lower
than joe biden's approval rating
okay i don't know what that means
but i appreciate the support that's for
sure
uh
yeah
thank you to tay d jordan ryan four quay
and mo cash
for the twitch prime subscriptions 34 35
and 36 appreciate that here's the judge
the judge maybe is back from some of his
pizza
let's listen to a few voicemails i do
want to keep working on these voicemails
let's go to our first voicemail here
hey beckham so i've been uh thinking
about this colin powell story about how
he
you know
contracted coveted and died even though
it was a breakthrough case and
he had blood cancer so he was high risk
and
yadda yadda i think the real story here
is that it's been six months
since the general population has had
access to the vaccine
six months we should have reached herd
immunity by now if everyone did what
they were supposed to right and colin
powell should never have been exposed
to clover 19 which would then kill him
true it should not even have gotten this
far
and a lot of these deaths the majority
of them most likely
could and would have been prevented
had people just stop believing all this
propaganda nonsense from fox news or
wherever they're getting it from
and gotten vaccinated
in particular yep no that's completely
accurate completely accurate
uh let's see what else we got
hey david um i'm a big fan of the show
um i noticed he got blocked by travis
tritt on twitter
um and i just gotta say you got a real
dose of american justice there david
um i can't hide it i'm ecstatic that you
got blocked by the guy um
you know
i'm just so happy uh you got blocked by
travis tritt on twitter um
okay got it yes you're happy i got
blocked okay thank you
hey david my question's on the dennis
prager um
story you did
the problem i had with guys like him
they going around trying to get coveted
but then they're going to go over there
and get this mono corneal stuff and
everything like that
these are the people we should not be
treating if they're going to go out
there and purposely get the covet
then why even treat these duck masses
all right that's a position certainly a
position someone someone uh can take i
don't disagree with that
uh let's see what else we've got here
hey david pakeman
today you referenced
a right ring talk show host named dan
bongino yes
i can only assume that you intentionally
mispronounced his name as a yes
correct since you usually do a little
better
job researching your material right i
know his name is not pronounced dan
bongino
his name is actually dan bongino
thank you
sir
for letting me know
what the right
pronunciation
of his name
is
okay
hey david has it been lost on everybody
that trump's new social media platform
is the same name
as the official soviet newspaper
so hey there it is
freedom
okay
hello i just wanted to say i don't like
you
what the hell was that
very very strange
hi david roston town hall for joe biden
especially that question what do you say
to somebody who is down and who is
watching right now
i would have expected
joe biden to reply like the last
president who we all know was the
greatest president we ever had
possibly a little bit worse than lincoln
but actually no about ten times better
than lincoln and say uh you're a bad
reporter yeah well it was a person in
the audience you could have attacked the
person in the audience i guess um yeah
some good and some not so good in that
town hall
for um
for for joe biden hi david i'm watching
your fox news desperately trying to
resurrect war on christmas video
and when you said dan bongino's name
as dan bongino i could not stop laughing
that was
the funniest either mistake all right
well someone someone's liking it all
right uh let's see i think this is from
the eggman
hey dave
watching jim jordan question merrick
garland is making me absolutely stick to
my stomach merrick garland should just
look at him and say you allowed boys to
be raped in a wrestling team you [ __ ]
[ __ ] well okay all right eggman's on
fire uh we're gonna have to get away
from that that we don't want any issue
with that
um let's see what else we've got here
oh brother
hmm
okay
hi david do you think joe biden really
dropped the ball at the town hall last
night when he didn't call anyone a bad
reporter asked pandemic advisors about
injecting disinfectant or in sight of
violent insurrection yeah yeah there
were a lot of those hits that uh biden
certainly missed
um
[Music]
yeah that's that's that's absolutely for
sure
let's see
um uh-oh
hey david and sarah from mass i just got
to say uh
about that um anti-semitic [ __ ] i mean
you're really uh drawings reaching for
straws dude think about it you think
people who went against the mafia and
wanted to take the mafia down with
anti-italian
i mean seriously
well that's interesting that you
mentioned that let me show you a very
very interesting clip
um
which you might uh maybe maybe will
change your mind okay let's take a look
at this
my name is melanie rattler
um i'm a veterinarian i was a former
teacher in phoenix union high school
district i'm a cloning expert with 35
years experience
and i was a consultant to the cdc
veterinarian cloning expert teacher cdc
consultant i owned a pharmacy pharmacy
owner i want to tell you that
this vaccine
this um covet vaccine is a deadly poison
that's it i'm just going to tell you
that
everybody that takes it is damaging
their immune system
and
they're talking about this being given
to children now it's going to destroy
them
you need to do more research on it i'm
an expert on it and i'm telling you
that's what it's doing
all right the next thing is my next
topic is the crt
um
i agree with what both of these people
said um but you know what
if you want to talk about racism if you
want to bring it in then let's bring it
in
let's get to the bottom of if you want
to talk about racism she will say
something as racist as anything you can
imagine 15 seconds from now the bottom
of it you're talking about white
supremacy
okay let's get to the very bottom of it
every one of these things the deep state
the cabal the swamp the elite you can't
mention it wait for it but i will there
is one race
that owns all the pharmaceutical
companies and these vaccines aren't safe
they aren't effective and they aren't
free
you know that you're paying for it
through the increase in gas prices the
increase in food
prices you're paying for this
and it's being taken from your money and
given to
is everybody ready
i want to make sure everybody's paying
attention now okay she's listed shadow
deep state pharmaceutical companies
gas prices she's about to blame she's
about to tell us who's to blame for all
of it okay these um
pharmaceutical companies
and if you want to bring raised into
this it's the jews
folks
she has solved every plot problem
known to man
she is she and guys that is a cdc
consultant
pharmacist cloning expert veterinarian
expert on vaccines
so it's kind of like a case closed type
of uh
situation
um
let me see here we're banning a lot of
people we can barely keep up
oh wait a second this one is unbanned i
accidentally unbanned one wrong person
but now i now we've banned all the right
people
okay good
okay wow it's getting crazy i want to
say thank you to a bunch of people who
just signed up signed up via twitch
prime including dog on mountains new
member number 37 today
druish 92 is new member number 38
chad villarreal is new member number 39
laser patent
is new member number 40
and then over on the website i can't
thank enough glenn hughes glenn hughes
just signed up at
joinpackman.com
and his new member number 41 as we await
the resumption of this trial all right
as we stand by i'm going to step away
refresh my water maybe grab some almonds
and then i'll be back with everybody
very very soon stand by
all right welcome back everybody um we
are trying to keep up with uh
banning all the people we need to ban on
both twitch and youtube mostly youtube
is where the toxicity is today
although
that can really vary
um from day to day just getting our
super chats adjusted here a little bit
um i apologize to anybody offended by
the vile and disgusting things that are
going on
um but we're going to uh just keep keep
ban hammering them um as much as we can
i want to say thank you to amithest for
subscribing via twitch prime your new
member number 42 today very much
appreciate that we are about 15 to 20
ish minutes from the resumption of day
one of the kyle rittenhouse trial
i am going to
um
okay hold on we gotta
keep banning people
just keep banning the moderators please
keep banning them
um
we're this is jury selection today so
they got a bunch of it done in terms of
just initial people where the judge says
this person probably shouldn't be on the
jury or the jury as some say
um the next step will be that the
prosecutors and defense attorneys will
get to ask their questions
of the
potential jurors
and in terms of when testimony opening
statements will start it could be
tomorrow but tomorrow might include jury
selection as well
so all we can do is wait and um and and
monitor
um
we are going to be streaming tonight as
well the final rallies in the virginia
gubernatorial race and then tomorrow
night we'll be streaming live results as
well as a stream tomorrow with day two
of the trial so a lot of streaming and i
really appreciate everybody who's here
uh and everybody who's watching i think
there's gonna be a lot of very very
um
important uh things
taking place
let's look at some
uh super chats mr pakman sir love your
bigly strong moderation i appreciate
that
on the stained apron website david is
described as a poor tipper the entry
reads spence spent most of his time in
the bathroom with his guy friend
and ordered a lot but didn't eat a thing
tipped about five percent so i'm mixed
on this david whackman person because
they say horrible things but at the same
time they've spent probably a hundred
bucks sending super chats which then
just helps our store our uh our you know
influence
grow
so i kind of am inclined to let him do
it jose says how would he treat a blm
supporting juror good question
swami live says one might say that lady
is giga cringe giga cringe
um
a few more people to ban
yeah it's crazy how many people were
having to ban
folks almost choked
thank you to tyler young who just sent a
hundred dollar super chat by far the
biggest today
and thanking the the troll david
wachmann or whack man
for influencing tyler to want to send a
hundred bucks wow
that's gotta piss off the trolls that is
something else
um
okay
let's do a few more of the yeah
we got interrupted with voicemails
um but let's go back to it but we do
have some from whitney
whitney who we haven't heard from at all
today so i was wondering about um what
you said about um
obama being muslim and i don't think
that there should be like rules or
regulations on
um on my
uh
i'm religious
um yeah there aren't you you're allowed
to be muslim and be president
about five years ago i was remembering
like some of my friends went out to cal
colorado from vermont it was like whoa
this is exactly like
vermont just
like
like really bland like
suburban area all right then back to
eric from mass
hey david this is eric from mass i'm
giving you permission to use this um
as an intro if you'd like or a party or
a show
okay ready
welcome to the david pacman show brought
to you by pfizer merck
and moderna and now here's the man with
the plan the host with the most he is
the best political broadcaster on the
internet
gave it pac-man
obama
okay
let's keep going
uh
all right obviously if we were funded by
those companies we would we would
disclose that
i want to make sure people know that
dave as you know i live in western and
new york i call it west virginia new
york because
most people here think they live in the
south
they fly confederate flags or dale
earnhardt flags it's just absolutely
racist but let me and they all deny they
are but let me ask you this question
these are the signs i see that bother me
so much okay in people's yards biden
likes miners i see that all over and now
i see unvaccinated lives matter
dave is the latter of those two
racist i mean of course it is right and
then biden likes miners how many times
has trump been accused of all these
assaults
it's absolutely insane so anyway dave i
s i'm surrounded by all these people
that are
that are escaped from reality and i want
to move i want to leave west virginia
new york i freaking hate the people
around me yeah
what part of america can i go to where i
don't find these people all around me pf
i can't afford to live in boulder
colorado or eugene oregon i've already
lived there but in a bus not in the real
house well where could the eggman go
liberal places that are not super
expensive what what are some ideas for
the egg man
not super expensive
i mean i guess it depends on how
expensive there are
there are parts of lots of states that
aren't like there are parts of north
carolina that are aren't conservative
although i think they're expensive parts
oregon oregon as some say
um washington state
parts of michigan minnesota yeah i mean
there really are a lot of a lot of
possibilities for the eggman that's true
all right let's move on
and look at a couple others
hey david my name is john from virginia
and i was looking at a youtube short a
few days ago and the guy said a really
cool quote that i thought your
audience might be interested in
um and so the quote is
about uh anti-vaxxers and what you can
say to them
and what they believe so it's you're
looking for random facts to support the
conclusion you've already drawn
rather than drawing drawing it can con
jesus christ
cut that okay all right we're cutting it
um let's see
see what else we've got here
another one from wit
so um
i have like uh some of the misfortune of
meeting like a lawyer that works with
like mainly jewish people
okay that sounds like a bad experience
wit
but like one of the things that i worry
about with like the jewish community is
like the amount of like disconnect they
have with like our dating circle and
like what's
oh man
kosher with society and what's not
because i feel like there's a lot of
like blowing smoke up their asses as far
as like when it comes to
you know what they can have and what
they can't have and
um
just like how reciprocal like the
relationship between like the jewish
people and just like other
people that are not jewish
um
like in their relationship to like
society i feel like it's getting kind of
like
you know there's a definitely like
warped sense of
um
like authority
where
i don't know what she's talking about
guys i really really don't i just have
no idea
david it's sarah from math again how you
doing buddy um
let's see let's run it down uh
let's see natural immunity oops
ivermectin
oops
russiagate
is he having a medical event he then
called it back immediately
hey david it's eric from mass i want to
read a tweet from you uh not from you
to you from a doctor remember believe
all doctors dr adam and
eve
okay yeah keep working on that my friend
hey david this is uh justin from
maryland um
recently watching one of your
competitors shows yesterday the majority
for them i'm not sure if you heard of
them or not they're slightly lower than
you on the subscriber side but um
they
the the main guy there is peter
he um
just kind of just curious because he he
was i know doctoring is the right word
but calling you out with the fact trying
to say that you're only working
four days a week
so that you know as a big surprise um
because now that means he can work four
days a week so
not really too sure why he based his
schedule off of you is that true did sam
do a thing about how i only work four
days a week i would like to see that
that was from thursday does anybody know
if that's true if anybody could get me
that i would be interested in that
anybody know if that's legit
sam saying why does he have to work five
days if i only work four
sam who takes thursday's off sam only
works for oh okay yeah
anyway if somebody if that's real i'm
not going to spend time just reading
chat about it um send it to me info
davidpakman.com
we're moments away from the resumption
here i want to welcome everybody who's
joining me this is day one of the kyle
rittenhouse trial we are in the middle
of jury selection right now the
potential jurors are getting pizza
they're having pizza there in the
courtroom they have also been warned by
the judge do not
go to the bathroom in the courtroom go
out and go to a restroom
that's not a joke
um
the judge did
mention that to people
i want to say a huge thank you to jason
and kayla bailey
they just signed up for a perfect year
membership on my website using the
coupon code elements of bathrooms and
together they represent new member
number 43 today also want to say thank
you to rosas dioro or it could be said
rosa de oro which would be gold roses in
spanish for the twitch prime
subscription number 44 today very much
appreciate that
um today is really we are actually uh
i am sort of committing to
november being
mustache november that's number one
but number two
power stream november
where we are looking to do more streams
in a month than there have been in a
really long time today alone getting off
to a strong start november first two
streams today we have the kyle
rittenhouse stream right now and then
later tonight i will be streaming the
final rallies in the virginia
gubernatorial tomorrow there will be
more streams we will have day two of the
kyle rittenhouse trial and then virginia
election results tomorrow night as well
as new jersey a bunch of mayoral results
and a whole bunch of different things so
i would love it for you to support the
work that i'm doing sign up on my
website joinpakman.com all of these
other different platforms
they want to take slices they want to
take slices you get a youtube super chat
you get a twitch prime subscription you
get patreon you get patreon all these
different things they want slices slices
two five six seven ten percent should be
illegal but it's not but on my website
we keep everything but the two point
percent that we uh pay to process credit
cards so i very much appreciate
everybody who signed up today uh
joinedpakman.com is the place to go
here's an additional incentive wherever
we get to by the end of today's stream
with whatever number
when tonight's stream starts we won't go
back to zero we'll start at the same
number so then we'll almost certainly
get to a hundred open phone lines
tonight and have a real party i think
it's gonna be great
i think it's going to be really really
great
let's listen to a few other
super chats here i'm sorry voicemails
again i just got to compliment you man
what you're doing is really working
calling people stupid and uneducated and
fools and dummies thank you
i think that's really gonna work i think
um next you should um
uh
[Music]
advocate for uh people just getting
dragged out of the house and uh having
the vaccine given to them while they get
held down by six people
you know stuff like that is really
working in your favor and you should
yeah i would never advocate for that
i've i've never done anything even close
to that i can't imagine why anybody
would even suggest that
hi so whitney garbody um i was actually
really
interested in like sharing stuff about
like uh our heritage and dna and stuff
like that it's like
one of the
upsides i felt like was not really
taking trump like that seriously um just
because i was like oh yeah like what
about like my cultural background or the
people who
you know were in my family have to do
with like what's going on with my life
today um just historically i feel like
it's interesting like if you didn't take
it seriously or if you feel like you
know maybe
the bullying wasn't like that serious
even though i really do think it is um
but now that it's probably open i feel
like you know like braves is the best
way to be and like is open up front
because
i do feel like when things are like
hiding underneath okay uh next voicemail
hey david
uh albert einstein said coincidences are
just god's way of staying anonymous
well i'm going to give you a coincidence
uh you can you can call up jesse
dollamore and ask him this but i emailed
him a copy of the declaration and the
constitution signed by me because you
can do that online by the way
you can sign it and print it out all you
want and i sent it into the president
and said yo i want to declare
independence from maggie savage's you
know read the part about insurrections
or watch jesse's video about marjorie
taylor green and her attempt to
understand what the declaration meant
when she totally failed and completely
doesn't understand what it means and
actually
okay i don't know what on earth that's
about
um but it's really really wacky i want
to say thank you to people dumping in
memberships on my website marvin rash
just signed up using the coupon code
elements of bathrooms
joshua phillips is a new member on my
website using the coupon code felony21
kenneth alexanderson just signed up
using the coupon code felony21 and aud
evar stenberg just signed up using the
coupon code
elements of bathrooms a crazy dump of
memberships big massive dumps
and what happened if you watched the
election i was called by the biggest
people
saying congratulations political people
congratulations sir you just won the
election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and i'm sure you
felt that way
this election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps big massive
dumps exactly and those uh happening
on the um
happening on the website as we speak
let's see if we've got a couple more
voicemails
uh
same guy called back i don't know if
he's making any more sense
so just so you know david i just handed
you the the solution to gravity by the
way the solution i didn't know gravity
was a problem we were trying to solve
but there's a black hole at the center
of every atom which is why we can't see
it we're not supposed to
um if there's a black hole at the center
of every atom that means there's a
wormhole at the center of every atom
what are you made up of wormholes
well you're made up of atoms
which have wormholes hidden at the
center but
if you dig a little deeper into what
that means i can tell you that einstein
did not find the atomic bomb
we made the atomic bomb from an equation
that was meant for something else right
e equals mc squared
energy equals mass light is energy
so if you take energy and stick it into
your eyes
well you make matter it's called gray
matter
you know gray aliens you think that's a
coincidence david not at all you think
light
turning into matter is is not real but
they did it they even turned matter into
light just recently not at all
which i didn't you know i knew it was
possible but i didn't know if they'd do
it
uh-huh
cepha hyde yeah
so
that happened i want to say thank you to
alex creator for gifting a subscription
on twitch i also want to say thanks to
david slivens
for signing up via twitch prime you are
number 50
number 50. very very much appreciate
that as well as everybody who signed up
on my website we're just a few minutes
from the resumption of the trial
um let's see if we can get a couple of
other
voicemails in here some very very
interesting things
hi david this is rayna and i actually
have something funny um that isn't
follow-up to your broadcast about
how uh people judge was being mocked for
taking family leave and about how joe
brogan
and
some others
were saying that it should be reserved
for
the women in the relationship
yeah so when i had my last child
my husband who
is well he has actually retired air
force now
he was actually deployed at the time
that i had my baby my last my last baby
um six years ago
and
he
actually was offered
family leave
while he was away from home he was
halfway across the world in qatar
um and
okay all right very good yeah no leave
is very very important
um
that's for sure
um
let's see what else we've got here other
messages coming in
hi mr pregnant um
do you ever think that maybe going at
the anti-max guys the way they come at
us
you people
like hey you know what don't get the
vaccine you don't want it
you're gonna die go ahead you know
prove it to yourself because they always
gang up like
and they try to dominate all the time so
if you change it around a bit i mean
nobody wants anybody to die but you
can't
like i i i was listening to the t i'm
sorry i'm going off track here okay all
right we're gonna move on to the next
voicemail
hey david this is mike from daytona
beach florida
i've called a few times i
i've heard you talk about
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies and i know
you're standing and i don't know if
you've talked about some of the mean
coins
like doge or shiva highly memetic it's
not shiva it's shiba inu but shiva is
something else they just seem to me be
making a lot of news lately
um just wondering if you had any
thoughts on that and of course i don't
expect
you to put out any
uh investing advice yeah i mean i think
listen
um for someone to say that
it's illegitimate
to
make money from a meme coin
if there's no crime being committed
and it's not against the law
i don't really know what the argument is
like just it's kind of stupid but like a
lot of aspects of the financial system
are kind of stupid
um i have said before i bought um
a bunch of doge a long time ago
i have not purchased any shiva
but i did buy some shiba inu a while ago
and it's a tiny percentage of my crypto
assets and my crypto assets
are a tiny percentage of my overall
assets because it's highly risky and
speculative
but
that's what it is i mean i don't know i
don't know what else to say there's like
wha what could i possibly say about it
um
yeah
i want to say a huge thank you to edward
heath who just signed up on my website
using the coupon code elements of
bathrooms and his new member number 51
today also jose godoy
is new member number 52 today who signed
up on my website using the coupon code
felony21 it's such a highly discounted
membership
some attorneys general believe it should
be a felony and lastly thank you and
welcome to colleen swain who is new
member number 53 today on my website
whatever number we get to here
even if it's not 100 it will carry over
to the second stream which i'm doing
tonight um with the final rallies before
tomorrow's elections
and i think that that will give us a
really big leg up
in terms of making it to 100. also gold
hand has just thrown a twitch
subscription my way which i uh couldn't
possibly appreciate anymore we are four
minutes from the resumption of jury
selection in the kyle rittenhouse trial
there's a lot going on here
hey uh pacman what do you think of
um
the jewish women in regards to like
feminism like how does that
like apply to in the jewish world like
i noticed that uh like benjamin is
jewish but not hebrew but he seems to
have like different morals and values
who benjamin who what did you talk about
benjamin is
jewish but not hebrew what does that
mean
like more
like traditional
like christian values
than i've seen um most jewish people
have
and um
like uh
my mom has like really red hair and like
the same shaped nose as you okay and
we're moving on to the next voicemail
hey david long time listener first time
caller i tried to leave you a message
before and it went on too long so i'm
gonna try to make this one shorter in
reference to your video about if
progression should tank the bill while i
certainly understand where you're coming
from about for the message and for the
for the messaging of it why possibly
progressive should tank it to make a
point i don't think that would be a good
idea i think that if the progressives
are taking it
almost certainly nothing will get passed
the media will blame progressives yeah i
have an update on this today on the
basis of some things that bernie sanders
said over the weekend so check out my
podcast today because i addressed this
issue of kill the bill or not um very
very important
but i just feel like after a while about
like maybe having excuses like oh like
this is due to the holocaust and this is
due to holocaust there's so many
like
holocausts that it's hard to like
move on um
from like the standpoint of like
um
you know trying to
relate to
like the jewish community leaving
it's not racist at all no all right
we're going to move on let's get to some
super chats bayfoto says the judge wants
the jury to understand elements of
bathrooms
just in place anyone want just in case
anyone wants to play along says tyler
young i have gotten logical fallacy
bingo three times already from these
voicemails yes
um no shortage of logical fallacies
in in the voicemails today i want to say
thanks to justin watson justin just
signed up on my website using the coupon
code elements of bathrooms as we are
just moments now
from the trial resuming as i mentioned i
can be here until close to 3 p.m eastern
time then we've got some business calls
and then i'll be back for another stream
tonight
let's see what else we've got as far as
voicemails go
hi my name's chelsea i just heard an
interview with the man who said he was
just
done with them conservatives and that's
how i feel and i feel that every day
my mind is blown by what these people
believe right and i truly don't
think
that some of these people will come back
to reality
right if that's true
some of these people are republicans
what are the republicans going to look
like in 2024 yes we don't know the
answer to that
it's a good question today is like the
wildest voicemail day we've had um
in a really long time
it's been a long time since we had
voicemails these this crazy
uh
let me even see
what we've got here
a
lot of wacky wacky voicemails
let's see i actually just misplaced a
couple
here we go we only have a few minutes
left but i'll see if i can get to a
couple others
hi david this is miles
from arizona
i'm uh been a major fan of your show
for
a while maybe four years since
2016 election
i just have a question about
really the future of the progressive
movement ever since nina turner lost
we've kind of been in a state of
disarray
and i would appreciate if you could give
your
two cents on yeah i did a big piece when
nina turner lost i actually didn't think
nina turner losing
gave us any more information in the
sense that
i had already said the 2020 democratic
primary shows us that what's popular on
the left on twitter and reddit
is not necessarily representative of
the the democratic
establishment i guess i would say or or
how of how
the left is placed on the political
spectrum i've talked about that a lot
and they they said nina turner not tina
turner
um
yeah no that's
it's it's all it's all uh
it's it's i've laid it out in a number
of different segments which i think are
important um and a topic that we're
going to keep talking about clearly
hey david jason calling from albuquerque
um
hey so i was thinking you know the
vaccine is so
widely available in the united states
and uh the number of people who are
actually getting it
seems to be plateauing yes
so it seems to me that
you know whoever isn't vaccinated at
this point probably just doesn't want to
be vaccinated most yeah seems like it's
their prerogative you know i
i don't know what we're supposed to do
about that but
um
you know there's a
big win i think right now for labor
markets you know because of what's been
going on and everywhere you look there
are uh companies advertising hiring
starting at you know 14 15 16 an hour at
least that's my anecdotal experience
here in albuquerque
and it seems like that's a win that we
should take and i'm just wondering what
you think when is enough enough for the
unemployment expansion and the eviction
well the unemployment expansion is
actually already over
um
yeah so i i think the labor market issue
i don't think we're going to have a real
sense of where the label labor market's
going to shake out until we get past
this winter and see how kovitz doing and
fully let
the enhanced unemployment kind of like
shake out i think maybe march is when
we'll start to get
a better sense of it that's my
expectation that's my prediction
but
you know i don't know for sure i don't
know for sure hi david leslie from
arizona i saw your show the other day
with mike lindell and i was really
surprised that you would have
him on your show i think it's terrible
waste of time yeah you know some people
were angry that i did that i thought it
was absolutely delightful satire he
didn't even realize it um it was a good
time it brought a lot of new people into
our universe i thought it was not a
waste of time i thought it was
extraordinarily well do well uh worth
doing um just as a reminder i did
interview mike pillow a lot of people
might not
remember that
let's just look at a little bit of it
mike lindell
i thought that this was super funny
uh where is it mike lindell
i can't even find it on my own channel
if you can imagine that
and this is about to get going again
oh let's see i guess we're back on
to a seat it's uh doesn't have arms so
that's
more conducive to her situation
and uh we're
going to continue with the examination i
think the last thing that happened we
need to fill seat number 33
and i there was an intervening
uh
call up which was uh number
which number was she
the lady whom i excused because of the
loss aspect hospice
number 53 53. and i uh she was excused
by mutual consent
because of a family situation so let's
ask 54 to come up
and uh
oh yes thank you um
yeah yes
ma'am would you have answered yes to any
of the questions asked so far
thank you very much would you take 33
and then there was one of the jurors i
would understand number six i think
uh six first let's start with six in the
back row did you say that you were
unable to hear what's going on ma'am
no
what did i do wrong
oh i was close um 59 where's 59
59.
she said she had a hard time hearing a
hard time hearing
and
all right
i guess what i was told was that you
said that you're only hearing about 25
percent of what's been said
okay any reason this lady shouldn't be
excused
because we can't replicate that now
thank you ma'am uh thank you thanks for
letting us know
anybody else who hasn't heard things
okay
okay
uh and then there was uh
number 16 i think you are yes 16. what's
up
well
we'll start with that one
uh wait uh
you missed uh
some of what was said this morning yeah
okay
um any reason this gentleman shouldn't
be excused hmm
okay thank you sir
all right so we need to replace
number 16 um
number 55.
again if you can't hear please let us
know
and also we have
these devices here and
is anybody actively using one right now
anybody want to endorse this product
i do want to say thanks to catch me
later and gordon z hall two new twitch
prime subscribers really appreciate that
and welcome back everybody certified you
just heard him he's a state-certified um
language interpreter and this is the
highest echelon
and he can translate not only
flawlessly between english and spanish
which isn't as easy as you'd think
because there's things like idioms
well i tried to present that proposition
but i struck out
now if you translate that literally
it could become a baseball term but it
has nothing to do with it you presented
a proposition in front of the
board of inquiry and say more you lost
so there's uh and i could give a better
example you could too
but these are people at the highest
level and they can actually
do it contemporaneously while i'm
speaking english he can move it into
spanish for that gentleman
so
and he uses them all the time
and he's not even hard of hearing but it
improves his ability to adhere it so
he's using it for fun essentially oh if
you want one of these
and
i've got this poor lady standing here
would you
would you have answered yes to any of
the questions asked so far
bless you and move into uh
the the judge does seem eccentric
right i mean at minimum we can't i don't
want to say he's nuts but he seems
eccentric i know
she was in the original group
they have not yet been sworn right when
we start with them we'll have to uh
we'll have to swim but she's been sworn
you were sworn you were here
no sir she's been swearing the entire
time i want to say thanks to yapern for
subscribing via twitch prime coupon code
elements of bathrooms working on
jointpakman.com
okay gotcha
okay now we're we're all of our seats
are filled
so anybody else now with whose uh has or
has impressed an opinion as to the
innocence or guilt of the defendant
okay now let's uh let me ask um
is there anyone of you who cannot or
will not try this case fairly and
impartially
on the evidence given in the court here
today
and guided by my instructions regarding
our law
reach
a just and true verdict anybody who will
be unable to do that
is there anyone of you who is cannot
read speak and understand the english
language
no boy anybody who does not reside in
kenosha county
oh
um
number five what's up i live in chicago
i just recently moved
really you were living here and now
you've moved to chicago yeah all right
uh that uh
now you're registered to vote
you have a driving license
from
from kenosha okay
now you're legally living full-time in
illinois
okay and that's your intent to remain
there
yes it is any reason this lady shouldn't
be excused
okay thank you ma'am all right and there
she goes excuse you and no letter on
that
um
number 56 here we go
56 was about to be out of this and now
56 might be in
all right sir would you have raised your
hand in the answer to yes you would
can you let us know yeah just loose ties
to two of the witnesses that were listed
okay first one he was in the first set
of 10 people um officer jason krieger
his wife goes to the same church that i
go to okay
and
we've never disclosed or talked about
any details of the case
okay fine and who was out who was the
other one
her parents also go to the same church
and we'll never talk about any details
of the case okay
uh
do you have any other reason why you
would have raised your hand nope thank
you would you take seat number five
please wow and just like that
thanks to heihei helen for the twitch
prime sub appreciate it
all right anybody um
uh else who does not reside in kenosha
county
anyone who is unable to read speak and
understand the english language i guess
it's a little late for that but i'll ask
anyway in fact i have to ask um
is there anyone who's taking medication
at this time which could cause
drowsiness or impair reasoning power or
judgment
okay the only medication that could
cause drowsiness
impair your reasoning power or your
judgment what's up
medication the migraine medication and
migraine medication is uh
number 15.
and um so if i were to get a migraine in
court and i would take rescue medication
as they call it it would make a drop
okay now i will tell you it depends on
how driving it tells you because there
are some lawyers
you wouldn't need any narcotics to put
they wouldn't take anymore
if they were talking you'd go to sleep
so it's that pronounced yes okay
and you're on the medication at this
time or if you took it
if you got a headache you would i would
take it okay wow i'm gonna leave that
for examination by the lawyers
and i think too we've got spellbinders
here these are not the run-of-the-mill
lawyer uh so
i want to say thank you to alex creator
for gifting a subscription appreciate
that alex anybody else on the medication
issue anybody feeling ill today
oh there's another hand on medication
it's interesting to see this process
quite frankly
[Music]
i don't hear you ma'am i don't hear you
i'm not hearing you
i'm number 39 39 and what were you
saying yeah there's different
medications
oh no then you don't have to the
question is
is it likely to cause you to for to
become sleepy
is it guaranteed to cause you to become
sleepy
will it interfere with your reasoning
power or your judgment
okay now we do keep an eye believe it or
not on the jurors to make sure nobody's
nodding off
uh it can happen
and um
and also if somebody feels that coming
on don't don't hesitate to let us know
because we can take a break
if it's only involving five minutes or
maybe a little longer five and we can
deal with that
um or if it's
persistent we may ask you to do 50
push-ups here um
well all right
we will uh
we will we we want to we want to make
sure everybody
can the judge is behaving strangely
right can i do am i off on is this can
anyone tell me the judge is behaving
perfectly normally just having uh
something that causes you to have to
take medication we don't try we try not
to excuse people unless it's going to be
an interference so we're going to hope
for the best
uh and if you become drowsy or something
just let us know or if you have need a
bathroom break something like that just
get the attention of me the clerk or one
of the bailiffs and we'll we'll take
time that necessary
any question about that
you've been very cordial and kind with
me
and uh i'm done finally so let's turn to
the prosecution and uh mr binger
so now the the attorneys get an
opportunity to ask questions and see if
they want to strike any of these
potential jurors
oh yeah i thought that was taken care of
no they weren't here oh uh
would you attorneys just go speak with
sergeant beth for a moment
there was an issue that came up that we
need to
so there's going to be a brief side
conversation there um we are going to be
streaming this for about another half
hour then i've got to run to some
meetings but i may leave it just running
so we can see what's going on then i can
come back tonight we've got another
stream really powerful stream the last
of the virginia gubernatorial rallies we
are going to continue we're at 60
members we hope to open phones today
we're going to continue into the second
stream so we're not going to go back to
zero so i invite you to go to my website
joinpakman.com take advantage of this
coupon code elements of bathrooms it'll
save you a bundle
um let's listen
okay they're still doing they're still
doing nothing there
super chat's coming in tyler says this
is on par for managing jurors
scott says i think this line of
questioning is infringing on all of our
hipaas
tyler says confirm the lawyers are
spellbinders
wow
very very interesting
commentary
from people in the audience today
and it is really really something
um yeah there is a don rickles sort of
uh vibe to the judge although i think
don rickles was much more clever much
funnier
and uh
had a much stronger sense of comedic
timing quite frankly
much much more so
uh
yeah i don't know how long it's expected
to go you know generally they say a
couple of weeks it really it depends on
so many things
let's see if there was an update from
this morning
couple few weeks is what i heard two to
three weeks is still what they're saying
yeah
two to three weeks
james says i know the judge personally i
used to date his daughter for about two
years
this odd behavior is super normal for
him oh man that's funny
swaggy says the judge has been looking
too closely at sinks and showers
i think i have that
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers exactly
uh the judge reportedly does not like
toilets being flushed 10 to 15 times
though that we know stand back and stand
by
yep
not something that the judge
likes
in his chambers
let's put it that way
um
how long will this go okay so
my belief is
they're going to attorney questions for
jurors right now
prosecution goes first then defense
it's at the speed at which this is going
and given the fact that it's already
recently over from the other building
okay is there any one of you who has
a religious or moral objection to the
taking of an oath
okay would you all please raise your
right
one of your hands to signify
your acceptance of the oath either hand
do you and each of you swear your child
answers made to such questions fortunate
regards to your competency just it is a
during this action where the state of
wisconsin is plaintiff and kyle wright
house's defendant will help you guys
okay thank you
all right
and then did you folks resolve that
issue
okay
still in negotiation over this issue i
want to say thank you to tim leonard tim
just signed up on my website
joinpacman.com tim we love you here we
really do so appreciate your support
very very much
unclear what this issue is or could be
could could be anything quite frankly
it could be anything
cryptic number 57
57
would i'm going to
excuse you uh sir
you're you're excused
and called the uh
yeah you're going to get a letter about
future jury service
okay thank you sir wow
the clerk is going to give you the bail
is going to give you a letter thank you
sir
the bailiffs very active today
um
number oh we don't need a number do we
we're full
okay uh mr banger
it's all yours
thank you judge
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is tom binger i'm one of the
prosecutors on the case here
representing the state of wisconsin
the judge has given you a little bit of
information regarding the circumstances
surrounding this case and i just want to
ask a few questions regarding the events
uh surrounding uh the night of august
25th 2020 uh and that time hopefully
they'll zoom out and actually show us
the prosecutor if not i'm gonna keep an
eye out for other streams if someone
knows of a better stream although this
may be the only camera we just don't
know right now the name of jacob blake
there were a series of responses here in
our community
which can be labeled a number of
different ways but in general we had a
lot of people that came out onto the
streets protesting they were
right every stream seems to be just this
camera so we're at the mercy of the
court i guess that they controlled this
camera to which side or which beliefs
were right or wrong or anything like
that uh there are constitutional rights
to assemble and speech etc what i just
want to ask is
how many of you
came out physically on any of those
nights to participate in any of those
activities
to protest to
show your
support for any particular cause
anything along those lines
i'm not seeing any hands
how many of you have any close friends
or family members
who came out on any of those nights to
participate in any of those events maybe
to march maybe to protest maybe to
support one side one cause one belief or
the other and again i'm not trying to
put anybody on the spot about what your
beliefs are i just need to know if there
was any participation so let's start and
i'm gonna do my best to refer to
everybody's numbers here but i gotta
admit we've changed numbers so many
times that i'm not sure i'm gonna get
them all right this should be
interesting back row there you are in
seat number six i think you are actually
juror number 39 is that right okay
either way i think we know who you are
um you're raising your hand can you tell
me a little bit about that please
um
one please and it was kind of later on
who here was rioting in the streets that
night very well done first time chat
from a thousand wigs and a very very
good
chat was not allowed
[Music]
i think she's crying
you
know heart
and this is something that we allowed to
do with another family from the family
members and that
and
it was kind of a trying time at that
time
so i just want to
follow so your granddaughter did
participate in some of the
marching or protest things like that
right
later on okay
okay thank you is there anything about
your granddaughter's involvement in that
that would affect your ability to be a
fair and impartial juror in this case
now i think the judge has already kind
of gone through the whole discussion of
how we're going to be hearing testimony
and evidence in this case and only at
the end of that and hearing the
instructions from the judges to the law
will the jury be in a position to make a
decision here do you think that you'll
be able to keep an open mind listen to
all the evidence and testimony follow
the judge's instructions and only make
your decision at the end of the case
you don't know
you don't you don't think you'll be able
to keep an open mind throughout no okay
um
do you feel to use one of the judges
questions do you feel that uh
you you're not going to be as fair as
some of the other jurors that are
sitting around you
yeah
you feel that way
okay
your honor
i don't know that this juror can be fair
so i think it would be appropriate to
strike her for
mr
richards mr franklin
all right thank you ma'am and uh
you'll get a note from the bailiff um
you're excused ma'am number 58 to come
up please thank you to lawful waffle and
daryl soros rex for the twitch prime
subs
all right sir would you have raised your
hand and answered to any of the
questions asked so far
okay uh are you able to uh
shed those views and decide the case
exclusively as you hear and see the
evidence in this case
okay you may be examined further about
it but thank you please take seat number
six
thanks to manoa smith for the website
subscription
okay thank you sorry about that um i had
asked a question about whether or not
you had friends uh close friends or
family members that had participated in
in the any of the events here in kenosha
and uh we already spoke to one of the
jurors i know there were a few other
hands that i missed so if you could just
raise your hands again so i get
everybody okay in the front row here i
think you are jury number 23
yes okay
my son went down
was that on
the tuesday night august 25th when the
incident in this case occurred or was it
a different night do you remember
okay thank you very much um did you have
your hand up ma'am
okay you're seated for the record you're
seated in short 24 but i think you're
juror number 40 is that right okay
um just some friends from church did uh
um
okay uh out front of where oh okay um do
you remember what night that would have
been no i think it was later on
okay um did you participate in that at
all
okay would that affect your ability to
be a fair and a partial juror here okay
thank you
was there anyone else's okay um juror
number 29
i'm not quite sure if you're just
referring to the evening or during the
day
at any
were those businesses that you uh
knew like the owners or were involved
with in any way or just
is there anything about that that would
affect your ability to be a fair and
impartial juror in this case okay thank
you
anyone else's hands that i missed
okay thank you
so
um juror 29 touches on a subject that i
wanted to get get to next which is that
we i think are all familiar with the
fact that during this sequence of events
there were a lot of properties and
businesses here in the community that
were damaged some were destroyed with
fires others were the subject of looting
or burglaries things like that
so what i want to ask first of all is
how many of you were personally affected
by any of the arson violence looting
rioting whatever you want to call it
where your property your home your your
business anything like that was
personally affected by
anyone
no hands okay
do any of you have any close friends or
family members whose property
your home their homes their businesses
etc were directly affected by any of the
violence any of the property damage that
occurred around this period of time
okay i see a couple of hands let me
start in the back row there
i believe that you are in seat number
three but you are juror number 43 is
that right right okay
and my daughter had a business downtown
um
it subsequently closed okay um did it
was there any actual property damage to
the business okay what what was it that
caused it to close
black
people were going downtown sure
okay
that area sure i understand
is there anything about that experience
that would affect your ability to be a
fair and a partial juror in this case
okay could you pass the uh microphone to
journal number four next to you did you
raise your hand sir i did okay
well i had some coworkers that actually
live
in apartment buildings right
real close to uh
their car dealer and a couple other
places where
our trucks were started on fire so there
was a
a garbage truck
so
there was a mandatory evacuation of
those apartments so they had to find
other co-workers that can put them up
while this is awful
okay
um
and what part of town was that
specifically um i believe it was seventh
okay
is there anything about the experiences
that your co-workers had that would
affect your ability to be a fair and
impartial juror
just how crazy they said everything was
when they came in
okay
and do you believe that that would
affect your ability to be a fair and
impartial juror
that probably would no
okay thank you
um i think i saw at least one other hand
somewhere but maybe i missed it okay uh
juror number 40.
okay
and you said these uh the people that
owned it were friends of yours from
church
okay uh is there anything about that
that would affect your ability to be a
fair and impartial juror in this case
okay
anyone else whose hands i missed with
regard to the question of whether or not
you have close friends or family members
who had homes property businesses etc
that were damaged or affected or
burglarized or anything like that during
all these events
and i'm not seeing any other hands okay
thank you
i believe i the judge may have already
asked this question but is there anyone
uh in the group of 34 that is not
currently a resident of kenosha county
and i asked because we've had a couple
of already so i just want to make sure
all right
i want to continue along the line i was
just getting at about
the property damage that occurred to
some parts of our community and i know
that there were many people who live in
our community who felt vulnerable who
felt scared about what might be
happening to them to their homes to
their property i know jerk number 29
already mentioned helping to board up
some local businesses so i want to ask
this question
how many of you
yourselves personally
took steps
to protect yourself your family your
home your business
during that period of time that can
range from boarding up windows to
moving and staying someplace else some
people decided to take steps to protect
themselves with firearms or other
defensive weapons things like that
how many of you personally decided that
you needed to take those steps during
that period of time to protect yourself
for your family your home your business
okay
try and remember all the hands here but
if i uh forget i'll come back to you
let's start in the back row there juror
number 43.
um
my daughter my son-in-law and her baby
they left town
so
i was protecting myself
the best way i knew how
i just go home stay home and
get anywhere
okay
thank you uh could you pass the
microphone to juror number four next to
you yes yeah we uh ended up moving all
the vehicles to the back side of the
house because we had people walking down
the sidewalks and rooms
so
i made my wife pretty nervous
all right
interesting i'm nervous on that one sir
no okay um was there anyone else in the
back robe okay uh juror number i believe
you're juror number 58 is that right
okay
uh we just we just took our family one
of my entire family we went on to the
county for one of the nights
do you have um okay i was gonna ask you
a family out there okay thank you
all right um let's stay in the jury box
here while we're all close by um i
believe that
was there anyone else in the jury box
itself that had other henries okay uh
juror number uh 14. okay
we just spent a few nights uh at my
place of employment because when there
were rumors of going after school
and what where do you work at uh during
charity okay
um and so you were concerned about
possible damage to the church or looting
or something like that
okay thank you
um i believe that um and i found
everybody's numbers here um
are you jordan or 46 okay thank you
i went to my sister's house in bernie
stay there for a few days okay
thank you
um
where else let's see do we have any
other hands uh in the jury box or over
in the corner okay let's do the front
row here did anyone else raise their
hand the front row okay uh juror number
23.
okay
so uh am i correct in assuming that uh
you didn't have a gun before this but
you decided to purchase one during this
period of time
okay
all right thank you
um jury number 25 did you raise your
hand sir
we have out of the subdivision from
southwestern prairie we assembled a
neighborhood watch
okay basically
sure did you ever have any problems no
we did okay that's good
all right um and then over here in the
chairs i know there are some hands and
i'm sorry i didn't catch everybody let's
start in the far corner there juror
number 11 i believe okay
oh there we go
we pulled our cars to the back of the
house
and
we
closed our doors made sure everything
was locked
we also have a bus for protection
and we moved uh we had a blue light out
in front of our house in support of the
police but because of the riots we're
concerned about the safety around the
riots
okay okay all right thank you very much
so thin blue line calls the protesters
rioters i mean you know okay
yes sir
we didn't have any damage or any
problems okay
all right was there anything else that
you did personally other than that
okay thank you uh i know there were
other hands i'm sorry i missed uh let's
go to
where am i on the list are you
ah i got my numbers here are you
yes
yes sorry i'm trying to follow the map
here yes
and all our neighbors got together and
had a good watch
out
okay
thank you very much anyone else over
here in the chairs whose hand i missed
okay was there anyone else in the whole
group anyone else whose hand i missed
i kind of jumped around a little bit so
i'm sorry almost had a sneeze but he
suppressed it
now
there were many reactions
to
the
shooting of jacob blake by a kenosha
police officer
and i think we can all agree there were
people that felt that they wanted to
exercise their constitutional right to
assemble peaceably and protest
is there anyone who feels that um it
would be inappropriate for citizens to
take to the streets and peacefully
protest what they consider to be
something that was unjust
is there anyone who feels that that is
inappropriate
okay does everyone understand the
difference between that and
taking violent actions such as property
damage arson looting things like that
does anybody understand that there's
there's a big difference between those
all right folks unfortunately we've come
to the point where i've got to go um i
have some meetings coming up this is
going to be a long trial this is jerry's
selection we're going to be back
tomorrow with more of the trial i'm also
going to be back tonight with the last
rallies in the virginia gubernatorial
election so i hope people will join me
tonight i appreciate everybody who's
been here today um i've got to run as i
mentioned at the start of the stream i
had about two and a half hours of this
oh looks like a coke maybe a coffee
um we're going to be covering the trial
so we will be back with everybody
tomorrow and um there are dozens and
dozens of streams on youtubes if you
want to continue watching this exact
same stream they're on the home page
very very easy all right so i would
leave it running except i need this
computer for my meeting zoom meetings
etc
we will be back with everybody tonight
tonight thank you